oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oh là là que soulève cette émission
ce soir on n'a jamais été aussi nombreux
auto battable ça veut dire que sur cette
émission je peux vous le dire on perd de
l'oseille c'est clair c'est les
honoraires il faut le savoir on l'a dans
la tête spéciales y tenez le vous le dit
matthieu delormeau
non je vous ai pas appelé sera bizarre
je vous le dit bertrand chamerois il est
autour de la table ça va ça va gilles
verdez sympa sympa erika moulet en fait
je vais prononcer un mot dans un instant
et aux mots clés erika moulet sera
persuadé qu'il y aura un film porno
derrière vous ne trouvez pas un petit
peu coquin aujourd'hui car tu vous qui
adhèrent jeter cours ou pas cyril un oui
un problème de ce qui se passe il faut
que vous vous veniez ici parce que là il
ya quelque chose qui se passe que les
gens ne doivent pas voir
excusez moi mesdames et messieurs il ya
un problème je vais reprendre l'antenne
pendant quelques instants
il y as derrière vous cyril des gens
mais si copule
n'étiez pas dans la jungle au nom tu as
la peau sucré ah oui très sucrée mais
ferme et [ __ ] la touche pas à mon pote
les titres non mais si fidel jsk la
politique attaque fragile on a du citron
on a du cran on a deux écrans à bien
vous remettre en forme
oui tout va bien oui je veux fava de
quoi dieu ouais ça vous voulez peut-être
1,9 avant de démarrer mais elle a
reconnu la poule elle a reconnu la poule
il a deux amours
[Applaudissements]
mais
leurs pas j'ai laissé mon entrée des
cours d'arabe sa bataille
e
moi ça tombait de bd wassa es ab des
manoirs et baissière y aller on parlera
de koh lanta koh lanta qui était en
pleine jungle à la nation
ce cri du coeur
hé hé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va vous vous avez vu des stars un
témoin
[Musique]
c'est à moi je sens
bastard
[Rires]
[Musique]
go
coutu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ragot